i love all things nostalgia especially
when it comes to food and i'm so excited
because we're bringing a retro recipe
back to life let's take a little trip
down memory lane together
shall we the decade is the 1950s
welcome to the nifty 50s
baby boomers are jitterbugging at the
sock hop in their poodle skirts
and playing with their hula hoops pogo
sticks
and slinkies parents are cruising in
their crossly station wagons
with their 2.5 kids heading to their
suburban homes
it's the golden age of television now
that 8 million american homes are
equipped with
tvs and wholesome shows like i love lucy
and leave it to beaver rule the airwaves
while john wayne elizabeth taylor and
marilyn monroe reign supreme on the
silver screen
[Music]
the term rock and roll was coined as
chuck berry
little richard and elvis presley burned
up the charts
and hot out of the oven it's tuna noodle
casserole this delicious dish was number
one in the 1950s
thanks to its affordable easy to find
ingredients
including tuna noodles and cream of
mushroom soup
and its quick and easy prep time of just
around half an hour
although tuna noodle casserole rose to
fame in the 1950s
the word on the street is that the
recipe's first appearance can be traced
back to a 1930 submission
to sunset magazine by a woman who went
by
mrs wfs for a dish called
noodles and tuna fish and casserole
and before that a flaked fish and white
sauce dish
known as cod a la bechamel was
casserole's cousin from the late 1800s
a decadent dish with a rich history
ani i'm home darling you're
home i made tuna noodle casserole
nifty honey fourth time this week it's
only tuesday
i know how keen you are on it it's all
worth it
for that first delicious bite of tuna
noodle casserole
mom can i have some more
i love you mom
[Music]
you